the underlying problem Remains the Same
you can't simply grow at 0.5 or 1% and
hope to sustain four or 5% annual growth
in public expenditure there comes a
point where you either have to increase
taxes or or borrow more which leads to
more taxation in subsequently so the
fundamental problem Remains the Same
we're a relatively low growth uh country
at the moment the fact that we're
growing faster than the Euro Zone which
the remainers hate to be reminded of for
me is neither here nor there because you
essentially we're both very slow runners
and to say that you're the fastest among
people who can't run very fast is
neither here nor there you got to look
at what's happening in the US and Asia
which are really driving growth right
now you know they're getting 3 4% a year
and we can't simply just stumble along
at one or one and a half%